[Music]
the spidey at Starbucks none is from the
same marketing geniuses behind a few
other viral pranks they're called think
moto of remember the devil Davey attack
yeah that's been viewed nearly 54
million times and we got the secrets on
how think moto always manages to scare
the living daylights out of folks these
pranks feel so real it's no surprise
they get a big reaction yes I'd be
running to James purse lay is one of the
creative geniuses at think moto the
company behind these pranks that have
become some of the Internet's most viral
moments we take the elements of a movie
and put it in real life and it becomes
relatable for devil baby they rigged an
animatronic baby inside a
remote-controlled carriage combining
technology with art worthy of a
Hollywood blockbuster in this super
market gag
they created electronic food that comes
to life and got Seth Rogen to help out
with the voices hey you just grabbed my
face the funny thing about doing these
viral videos is you never know how
people are gonna react but not all of
their stunts are electronic they've
employed movie makeup artists to create
lifelike zombies to spring on the
unsuspecting public
but their most impressive pranks are the
big scares like this psychic fear fest
and those eyes it's pretty easy
do it when I want to add a zombie hidden
under the floorboards and you've got a
recipe for horror riding by value
but this coffeeshops thought for the
movie Carrie may be their most elaborate
using hidden wires weights and
electronics to give customers a
telekinetic fright they'll never forget
you know this year think moto actually
hit a pretty cool milestone with their
prank for the movie the ring the video
racked up more than 200 million views on
Facebook in just 24 hours
[Music]